[Music]
when you see your favorite pop star do
you ever wonder what they look like as
Disney characters
if so you don't have to wonder any
longer a talented artist created some
amazing photos of our favorite
entertainers and reimagine them as
Disney Princesses princes and villains
you won't believe what Justin Bieber
looks like when he's transformed into an
animated character we guarantee you'll
be amazed if you're new to our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today
we'll be sharing photos of 10 pop stars
reimagined as Disney characters Selena
Gomez in 2013
Selena Gomez showed up at the 2013 MTV
Movie Awards looking absolutely stunning
in a beautiful Julien Macdonald gown the
mini dress was covered in countless gold
beads and the short length showed off
the singers curves and svelte figure
with her hair pulled back into a high
braid that cascaded down her shoulder we
couldn't help but notice she looked a
lot like one of our favorite Disney
Princesses can you guess which one
Princess Jasmine of course to really see
the resemblance between the two you have
to check out this photo of the popstar
reimagined as the Aladdin character as
you can see in this photo Selena's image
is morphed into Jasmine's features and
the results are breathtaking the artists
nailed the shape of Selena's face the
shape of her eyes her cute button nose
and her pouty lips wouldn't it be
awesome if Disney recreated the movie
Aladdin and used this cartoon image of
Selena as Princess Jasmine let us know
if this is a movie you'd watch down
below in the comments section the most
original comment we'll even get a reply
from us we can't wait to see what you
have to say gigi hadid when gigi hadid
hit the red carpet wearing this gorgeous
Tommy Hilfiger gown she definitely stole
the show at the 2017 Met Gala the dress
was described by many publications as an
asymmetrical Cinderella style gone
although we love Cinderella we'd much
rather see Gigi transform into Elsa how
about you even with darker hair
the supermodel still resembles the Snow
Queen a bit especially in the shape of
their eyes are you ready to see how
artistry imagine GG as the frozen
character well here she is the artist
superimposed Elsa's head onto GG's body
to create this fabulous image Elsa wears
her hair in a side braid and the blue
adornments in her hair really bring out
her big blue eyes were used to seeing
Elsa in her blue coronation dress but we
definitely think that this tan color
goes great with her skin tone
what if Gigi and Elsa decide to switch
worlds for a day Elsa would be hitting
up red carpet events and strutting her
stuff down the runway while GG rules the
kingdom of arendelle do you think they
would be able to survive in each others
worlds for more than 24 hours Justin
Bieber Justin Bieber has made a name for
himself in the music and fashion
industries he not only has awesome
vocals and amazing dance moves but he
definitely has a great sense of style as
well he can go from wearing street style
clothing to dapper three-piece suits in
the blink of an eye and no matter what
he has on he always looks as polished as
ever
when this talented artist decided to
give Justin Bieber a new look as a
Disney character it included an outfit
that we've never seen the senior wear in
real life are you ready to see the
animated version of Justin check him out
the beauty and a beat singer were
reimagined as none other than Aladdin
from the 1992 Disney film Justin where's
the main character's signature street
rat clothing including his sleeveless
vest and his baggy pants we also love
how the artists made sure to keep all of
Bieber's amazing tattoos in place and
incorporate them into this picture so we
already saw Selena as Princess Jasmine
and now we have Justin as a Latin does
this mean these pop stars are meant to
be together forever
we think so Adele in 2013 Adele attended
the Golden Globe Awards looking like she
just stepped off the cover of a fashion
magazine
the singer wore a black floor-length
dress designed by Burberry and she
looked stunning in the high-waisted
goddess gown to set off her look she
wore her hair in a dramatic up - and she
was dripping in the finest cartier
jewelry we didn't think Adele could get
any more glamorous than this but we were
wrong when we saw how an artist
recreated her image we were floored
many of the pop stars on our list have
been reimagined as princesses but Adele
was transformed into a wicked villain
are you ready to see what she looks like
as an animated character take a look at
her now
Adele's glam and elegant look was
completely revamped instead of looking
like a Hollywood starlet she is now the
half-human half octopus character Ursula
from The Little Mermaid to mimic
Ursula's hairstyle
Adele's hair stands on top of her head
her green eyes are more vibrant than
ever and you can even see some of her
tentacles in the background with a
live-action remake of The Little Mermaid
on the way don't you think it would have
been awesome to see Adele play the role
of the sea witch nicki minaj nicki minaj
is talented beautiful and a force to be
reckoned with in the entertainment
industry back in her pink friday days
the rapper was never seen without a
colorful wig very elaborate makeup and
eccentric outfits she was very animated
during her performances and you probably
didn't think she would ever be compared
to a disney princess in fact she was
probably the polar opposite of many of
the princesses in Disney's lineup but
that doesn't mean Nikki can't also be
reimagined as an animated character an
artist decided it was about time Nikki
left the real world behind and was
transformed into a cartoon character
but not just any character Nikki was
redesigned to resemble one of the most
powerful strong-willed and heroic Disney
Princesses of all time
can you guess who she was recreated as
here's your answer the rapper was
reimagined as the fighting warrior Mulan
nikki is still rocking her two toned
black and pink hair and she also wears
Milan's kimono her makeup is split
between natural and dramatic and we love
the contrast of the green eyeshadow and
her bright pink lipstick how about you
Rihanna at the 2007 MTV Movie Awards
Rihanna made heads turn in this gorgeous
gown the dress had a deep plunge in the
front and a small train in the back that
gave the dress a glamorous silhouette
this picture from the event served as
inspiration for the artist to reimagine
Rihanna as one of our favorite Disney
Princesses are you ready to see the
animated version of the singer here she
is
Brianna was
created as the New Orleans princess
Tiana from The Princess and the Frog
just like at the MTV Awards Rihanna
wears her hair in a short style with
blunt bangs her green eyes are
exaggerated to make them look even more
dazzling and mesmerizing and the artist
even nailed the shape of her nose and
lips perfectly
Rihanna's cartoon image wears Tiana's
shimmery blue gown like it was made for
her and we love how a few of the
singer's tattoos also made an appearance
in the reimagined photo with Rihanna as
Tiana who do you think her prince naveen
would be Selena Gomez we love Selena
Gomez's reimagined photo of jasmine so
much that's why we're excited to see the
pop star recreated as yet another Disney
character this time around the artists
used an image of Selena from the 2017
Met Gala she showed up to the
star-studded event with her boyfriend
the weekend together they definitely
looks like Hollywood's it couple Selena
wore a custom-made dress designed by
coach which she also helped to create
the dress had a bit of a 1930s flair to
it with a modern cut and a trendy
silhouette we think she looks so elegant
and graceful that night but what if the
weekend actually didn't take Selena as
his date to the gala what if he actually
showed up with a Disney Princess instead
get ready to see a reimagined photo of
Selena as a stunning animated character
here she is Selena was reimagined as the
Polynesian princess Moana the pop stars
head was replaced with mallanna's image
and as you can see she looks adorable
don't you agree Moana looks stunning
with her flower crown wavy hair and her
pink eyeshadow as she poses next to the
weekend we're really digging her look
Taylor Swift when it comes to many of
Taylor Swift's red carpet looks the pop
star usually wears gowns that are fit
for a princess she has been compared to
Cinderella many times especially when
she wears her beautiful blonde hair in
an updo but wouldn't it be awesome to
see Taylor reimagined as a character
other than a Disney Princess we're about
to show you what Taylor would look like
if she were reimagined as a villain here
she is the artist got rid of the big
dramatic ball gowns
the singer usually wears instead
she does the signature outfit worn by
Ozma of the 2000 film The Informers New
Groove as the villain tailor wears a
purple dress with a black cape and the
characters elaborate black and blue
headpiece tailor even has the characters
jagged and pointy body type and her long
and slender fingers do you think Taylor
looks better the way she is or does she
look more fabulous reimagined as a
Disney character make sure to tell us
your answer down below in the comment
section one lucky comment will even get
pin to our channel Bella Hadid do you
remember when Bella Hadid first stepped
foot on the red carpet at the 2017 Met
Gala the entire venue was speechless as
the supermodel donned a figure-hugging
jumpsuit designed by Alexander Wang the
sheer one-piece was definitely one of
Bella's best looks but something tells
us she would probably look even better
if she were reimagined as a Disney
Princess an artist definitely heard our
wishes and Bella was transformed into an
animated character was it Aurora from
Sleeping Beauty Merida from brave
Vala was actually recreated as the
beautiful Snow White the artists use one
of the pictures taken of Bella at the
gala the supermodels head was removed
and instead it was replaced with Snow
White image we just can't get over how
stunning this photo is Snow White is
rocking that sheer jumpsuit like it's
nobody's business and you know the
Disney character can never leave home
without a cute red bow in her head but
for this picture she's not wearing her
signature red hair accessory instead
she's wearing a grey bow headband that
looks awesome with her electric blue
hair Beyonce when Beyonce hits the stage
she's always guaranteed to look like a
million bucks
the formation singer has a team of
stylists and hair and makeup artists
that help her perfect her on and off
stage looks but even without all the
makeup and luxury outfits she's still as
beautiful as ever
we think beyonce is gorgeous just the
way she looks and we never really
thought she looks like a Disney Princess
until now here is the artist's
reimagined photo of
Yonsei transformed into the Native
American princess Pocahontas the singers
long brown and blonde braids were used
in the recreated image to give
Pocahontas a look that you've never seen
before
as a Disney Princess Beyonce still has
her same features including her almond
shape eyes her perfectly groomed
eyebrows her golden brown skin and her
full lips the only thing missing from
the reimagined photo is grandmother
willow and Miko and wouldn't it be
amazing if the artist recreated
Beyonce's husband jay-z as John Smith
now that's a picture we'd love to see
how about you
which of these photos of pop stars
reimagined as Disney characters do you
love the most
react in the comments section down below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching
[Music]